es oficial a partir del primero de enero
Croacia entrará en el espacio schengen
una noticia celebrada especialmente por
la presidencia del Consejo de la Unión
Europea
Croacia realmente ha hecho todo lo
posible para ser parte del espacio
schengen y estamos convencidos de que es
un mensaje muy positivo para todos los
ciudadanos europeos
ahora los ciudadanos de los estados
schengen podrán entrar y salir de
Croacia sin controles fronterizos la
candidatura de zagreb fue aceptada por
unanimidad por los ministros del
interior de los 27 países que conforman
la unión
pero no todos celebran la reunión de
este 8 de diciembre en Bélgica rumania y
Bulgaria también aspiraban a formar
parte del espacio schengen pero no
contaban con el veto de Austria que teme
que los flujos migratorios aumenten si
estos dos países entran en el acuerdo
Austria tiene más de 100.000 cruces
fronterizos ilegales de los cuales
75.000 no están registrados y esto a
pesar de ser un país sin salida al mar y
en medio de los países schengen Entonces
el no está funcionando lo que significa
que tenemos que mejorarlo
significativamente primero
críticas infundadas según otros
gobiernos europeos y en particular
Rumanía
bucarest considera que cumplieron todas
las condiciones para entrar en la zona
de libre circulación
lamentamos y realmente no entendemos la
posición inflexible de Austria
durante el año pasado Rumanía ha
demostrado ser un actor de pleno derecho
en la seguridad Europea
securitas y europea una seguridad
europea que los 27 creen que está en
peligro mientras aumentan las llegadas
irregulares la ruta migratoria de los
balcanes occidentales representa la
mayor parte del aumento con casi 140.000
entradas desde principios de año